[Musique]
et ils mentent et mentent et mentent et mentent par
exemple pendant des mois, le président Trump s'est
plaint à plusieurs reprises que la maison
lui avait refusé le droit d'arrêter d'appeler des
témoins pour contre-interroger des témoins et
ainsi de suite vous avez entendu M. Cipollone II
répéter ce menti aujourd'hui bien  J'ai avec
moi la lettre que j'ai envoyée à ce président
du comité judiciaire de la Chambre
le 26 novembre dernier invitant le président et
son conseil à assister à nos audiences pour
contre-interroger les témoins afin d'appeler
ses propres témoins et ainsi de suite et
j'ai la lettre le  Lettre de la Maison Blanche
signée par Mississippi Loney rejetant
cette offre,
nous avons été respectueux du Sénat,
nous vous avons présenté nos arguments et vous
ne méritez pas et nous ne méritons pas ce qui
vient de se passer, m.  Nadler est venu ici
et a fait de fausses allégations contre notre
équipe, il a fait de fausses allégations contre vous
tous, il vous a accusé de dissimulation,
il a fait de fausses allégations
contre le président, le seul qui
devrait être embarrassé, m.  Nadler c'est vous
m.  Sibal Oni dit que le président Trump est un
homme de parole,
eh bien, il est trop tard dans la soirée pour moi
d'entrer dans celui-là, sauf pour dire que ce
président Trump a donné sa parole qu'il
drainerait le marais, il a dit qu'il drainerait
le marais et qu'avons-nous  vu que nous avons
vu son avocat personnel aller en prison son
président de campagne aller en prison son vice-
président de campagne reconnu coupable d'un
crime différent son associé associé a
conduit Parnas sous le coup d'une mise en accusation la liste
continue c'est je suppose que la façon dont vous drainez le
marais est que vous avez tout  vos gens vont en
prison, je ne pense pas que ce soit vraiment ce que
voulait dire cette expression, mais aux
fins de la raison pour laquelle nous sommes ici aujourd'hui,
comment quelqu'un qui promet de drainer le
marais peut-il contraindre un de nos alliés à mener
une enquête politique - que  est le
marais
qui ne draine pas le marais qui
exporte le marais Je pense qu'il est
approprié à ce stade pour moi d'
avertir à la fois les directeurs de maison et le
conseil du président de se
rappeler qu'ils sont  s'adressant au
plus grand organe délibérant du monde, l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles il a mérité ce titre est
que ses membres évitent de parler d'une
manière et d'utiliser un langage qui ne sont pas
propices au discours civil lors du
procès Swain de 1905, un sénateur s'est opposé lorsque l'un
des responsables a utilisé le mot
pettifogging et  le président a
dit que le mot n'aurait pas dû être
utilisé Je ne pense pas que nous ayons besoin d'aspirer à
cette norme la plus élevée, mais je pense que
ceux qui habillent le Sénat devraient se
rappeler où ils se trouvent